[Music]  [Applause]  you're about to see bindi Irwin and  Derek Hough recreates that dirty dancing  moment  remember the famous lift in the lake et  has the photos bindi and Derek recreated  it and they did it perfectly we cannot  wait for Monday night's episode of  Dancing with the Stars when we'll get to  see it all these two are too cute  he actually chatted with bindi this week  and she told us about her and Derek's  plans for the Big Dance Monday and  listen from a little that I've got to  know you for the last few weeks I know  nobody puts bindi really really excited  about it and Derek is an incredible  teacher and so I've been showing these  guys what we've been doing